bonjour à tous je vous propose cet
après-midi de suivre l'audition de
Jean-Marie de laarue devant la
commission d'enquête sur les autorités
administratives indépendantes l'ancien
Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté a été nommé en juin
2014 à la tête de la commission de
contrôle des écoutes administrative
cette rupture va bientôt disparaître au
profit de la toute nouvelle Commission
nationale de contrôle et techniques de
renseignement et on a appris justement
cette semaine que Jean-Marie de laarue
ne ferait pas partie de cette nouvelle
commission jugé trop indépendant
sceptique sur la nouvelle loi sur le
renseignement il a été écarté par le
gouvernement et c'est pendant l'audition
vous allez voir justement que Jean-Marie
de la rue s'explique pour la première
fois sur cette situation vous allez
l'entendre il se dit préoccupé par les
les nouvelles méthodes de renseignement
et s'inquiète d'un affaiblissement des
contrôles induits par cette nouvelle loi
sur le renseignement voilà tout de suite
donc on écoute Jean-Marie de laarue je
rappelle que créé par la loi du 10
juillet 91 à la suite de l'affaire des
écoutes de l'Élysée cette commission
nationale contrôle les interceptions de
sécurité est qualifiée expressément
depuis l'origine d'autorité
administrative indépendante
française la loi du 24 juillet 2015
relative au renseignement prévoit son
remplacement par la Commission nationale
de contrôle et techniques de
renseignement et la compétence de
celle-ci par rapport à la CNCIS
elle est élargie à l'ensemble des
techniques de renseignement je pense que
dans votre propos introductif vous
reviendrez évidemment sur le rôle et les
compétences de cette nouvelle Aï dont la
nomination du président entraînera
l'entrée en vigueur de l'essentiel de la
loi relative au renseignement la
composition de la CNCIS est relativement
originale puisque sur ces trois membres
deux sont des parlementaires vous nous
direz également comment est désigné son
président oui som en pleine dans
l'actualité vous nous le direz on vous
fait confiance et on pourra apprécier
l'indépendance des Aï enfin la CNCIS
emploie 5 personnes et son budget
s'élève à 569000 € environ pour
2015 je pense que vous exposerez
également les règles de composition le
mode de fonctionnement de cette future
CNCT alors comme la loi le permet votre
audition fera l'objet d'un compte-rendu
publié dans le compte-rendu détaillé des
réunions des commissions qui est diffusé
en version papier sur le site internet
du Sénat par ailleurs votre audition est
ouverte à la presse et au public et elle
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo avant
de vous passer la par la parole pardon
le formalisme des commissions d'enquête
me conduit à vous demander de prêter
serment je suis également tenu de vous
rappeler que tout faux témoignage devant
notre commission serait pasible des
peines prévues aux articles 434 4 13 à
434 155 du code pénal en conséquence je
vous invite donc à prè descirements de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
leverz la main droite et ditite je le
jure je le jure madame le Président
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
selon l'usage habituel je vais vous
proposer de vous faire part de vos
observations durant une une dizaine de
minutes si vous voulez bien après quoi
notre rapporteur Jacques mzard les
membres de la commission qui le
souhaitent pourront vous poser leurs
questions vous avez la
parole madame la
Présidente au fond les autorités
administratives indépendantes vous le
savez bien mieux que moi sont employés à
trois fonctions la première c'est de
réguler certains marchés ou activités
économique la seconde la deuxème c'est
de d'autoriser ou d'agréer certaines
activités la troisième c'est le contrôle
d'activités d'agents publics sur des
domaines jugés sens
c la CNCIS cré vous venez de le rappeler
madame la Présidente par la loi du 10
juillet 1991 appartient évidemment à la
dernière de ces fonctions elle n'a pas
évidemment vocation à réguler quoi que
ce soit elle n'a pas à décider elle
donne des avis au gouvernement sur une
situation qu'elle constate en vertu de
la
Loi cette commission
a donc pour mission selon les termes
mêmes de la loi du 10 juillet 91 de
veiller au respect des disposition de
cette loi c'est-à-dire plus
précisément de veiller bien entendu à la
légalité des interceptions de sécurité
qui sont pratiqué
et je crois au-delà de pratiquer un
contrôle d'opportunité sur ces
interceptions
car la loi du 10 juillet 91 a marqué le
car caractère exceptionnel de cette
procédure qui figure en toute lettrre
dans la loi et la contrepartie de ce
caractère exceptionnel c'est que la loi
décide qu'il y a un quotat
d'interception de sécurité qui ne
peut-être dépassé à un moment déterminé
ce quota qui était de 2190 lorsque je
suis entré en fonction et depuis le
printemps de cette année fixé à 2700
interception de sécurité pouvant être
pratiqué en simultané sur le sol
national
dans ces deux manières d'exercer son
contrôle la commission rend donc un avis
dans tous les cas de figure que le
Premier Ministre qui a la décision en la
matière est libre naturellement de
suivre ou non il a été question à
plusieurs reprises soit en 1991 soit
encore au printemps dernier au moment du
vote de la loi sur le renseignement d'un
avis conforme j'ai toujours pour ma part
écarter cette idée car j'estime que
l'idée d'un contrôle en matière
régalienne d'une autorité
indépendante ne peut écarter évidemment
la décision gouvernementale en la
matière le gouvernement est
seul responsable de la politique qui
l'applique dans des domaines aussi
particuliers aussi relatives à l'ordre
public
ces interceptions de sécurité je le
rappelle aussi sont autorisés en vertu
de la loi pour cinq finalités que la loi
définit de façon assez
précise
essentiellement les préventions de la
criminalité et de la délinquence
organisée la prévention du terrorisme
les atteintes susceptibles d'être porté
à la sécurité nationale entendez par là
l'espionnage et le contre-espionnage et
de façon plus secondaire je veux dire
plus secondaire non pas dans l'intention
du législateur mais dans le volume des
affaires qui sont traitées les atteintes
à l'activité aux activités économiques
essentielles on va dire les choses comme
ça de la nation et enfin la les actions
tendantes à la reconstitution de
groupement de faê ou de droit dissous
par le gouvernement en vertu du code de
la sécurité intérieure voilà les cinq
finalités depuis toujours je le dis en
passant on reviendra sans doute sur ces
questions
la le thème la finalité la plus
importante en volume a toujours été la
prévention de la délinquence et du crime
organisé sauf depuis quelques mois
ou très précisément la prévention du
terrorisme dans les quatre derniers mois
que nous avons analysé c'est-à-dire ceux
portant jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août
euh représente 39 % des demandes alors
que la prévention du crime et de la
délinquence organisée en représente 38 %
c'est une marge étroite mais c'est un
renversement par rapport à tout ce que
nous connaissons depuis le début de
la de la commission j'ajoute que les
demandes sont présentées à la Commission
selon deux procédure une procédure de
droit commun qui laisse à la
Commission le temps qu'elle veut pour
statuer mais en réalité nous statuons
toujours dans les 24 he de notre saisie
ou même plutôt dans les 7 8h de notre
saisie les demandes arrivent en début d'
midi et nous les rendons en fin
d'après-midi au service du Premier
ministre concerné mais il y a des
demandes présentées en urg qui peuvent
nous arriver à toute heure du jour et de
la nuit il y en a une la semaine
dernière qui est arrivée à 3h du matin
et nous statuons en principe dans les 45
minutes nous avons fait les calculs
nécessaires moi je mettais fixé 1 heure
nous mettons encore moins donc les
services ne peuvent pas soutenir comme
ils l'ont fait quelquefois que leur
activité serait
par l'exercice de ce contrôle je tiens à
le
souligner alors sur la composition je
veux pas être trop long madame la
Présidente de la Commission vous l'avez
dit elle est originale puisque les
parlementaires ils sont majoritaires ils
sont désignés chacun d'entre eux par le
président de leur assemblée le
représentant actuel du Sénat et Monsieur
François Noël
buffet les le Président vous vous avez
posé la question est nommé par c
gouvernemental en principe par décision
du Premier
ministre sur présentation d'une liste de
trois noms qui est arrêté de façon
conjointe par le premier président de la
Cour de cassation et le vice-président
du Conseil d'État et c'est sur la base
de cette liste que le premier ministre
choisit un des noms traditionnellement
il a choisi toujours le premier des nom
qui lui été présenté j'ajoute que
traditionnellement
aussi ce nom est toujours celui d'un
magistrat de l'ordre administratif ou
judiciaire et dans l'histoire de la
commission il y a eu un seul magistrat
judiciaire qui a été mon prédécesseur
immédiate Monsieur Hervé Peltier
précédemment président de la Chambre
criminale de la Cour de
cassation voilà pour la composition vous
l'avez dit aussi la composition compte
depuis l'origine cinq agents trois
agents de catégorie C chargés deux
d'entre elles du secrétariat et la
dernière à la fois à us fait usage de
chauffeur et aussi d'officiers de
sécurité car nous sommes installés dans
des locaux où les conditions de sécurité
sont évidemment draconiennes parce que
nous sommes soumis au secret de la
défense nationale pour toutes nos
activités et puis il y a deux agents de
catégorie A qui sont toujours
traditionnellement depuis l'origine des
magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire il a créé il a été créé un 4e
poste de catégorie C en 2008 ce poste
n'a jamais été occupé et nous sommes
donc aujourd'hui dans des effectifs de
collaborateurs qui sont ceux que la
Commission avait en
1991 or depuis
1991 le champ d'activité de la
Commission s'est accru aussi bien en
effet en sus des interceptions de
sécurité que j'ai mentionné la
commission s'occupe
désormais depuis 2006 de l'ensemble de
des données de connexion relatives à la
prévention du terrorisme entendez par là
les adresse des téléphones portables
IMSI IMEI qui sont captés par les
opérateurs et mis à la disposition des
services qui en ont besoin notamment en
terme de géolocalisation des personnes
depuis le 1er janvier c'est l'ensemble
des données de connexion qui sont soumis
à notre contrôle mais un contrôle à
postériori alors que le contrôle sur les
interceptions de sécurité est à priori
je vais y revenir et puis enfin et
surtout depuis le 1er janvier également
nous sommes nous contrôlons toutes les
demandes fait par les services de ce
qu'on appelle la géolocalisation en
temps réel qui sont toujours là aussi
des demandes urgentes et qui vise sur la
base d'un article de la loi de
programmation militaire de du 18
décembre 2013 à sollicité du Premier
ministre l'autorisation de suivre
quelqu'un grâce à son
téléphone alors ce champ d'activité
s'est accru par conséquent nous sommes à
eff constant depuis longtemps et je dois
dire que pour l'instant nous sommes un
petit peu à la peine je vais y revenir
s'agissant du budget nous vous avons
envoyé nous avons envoyé monsieur le
rapporteur quelques données sur ce point
vous en avez rappelé l'essentiel madame
la Présidente nous sommes aujourd'hui à
569000 € annuels les la quasi-ttalité 80
% de ce budget est consacré aux
rémunérations nous n'avons depuis 5 ans
dépensé aucun centime en investissement
nous avons grosso modo 100000 € de
fonctionnement par an et tel que je vais
y revenir tel que j'envisage la suite de
cette année nous ne devrions pas finir
l'année et en rémunération et en frais
de fonctionnement je vais dire pourquoi
c'est tout simplement à cause des
perspectives de la future Commission
nationale de contrôle des activités des
techniques de renseignement
pourquoi vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente la loi du 24 juillet à créer
cette commission qui est appelée à
succéder à la CNCIS dès l'heure que son
président aura été
nommé il est très important pour moi et
je crois pour les services aussi qu'il
n'y ait aucune interruption dans le
contrôle de la commission sur les
activités de surveillance et par
conséquent il faut que dès le premier
jour de la réunion de la Commission
nationale de contrôle et technique de
renseignement un contrôle puisset
assurer sur les demandes qui seraient
présenté faute de quoi je craindrais
quelque peu que les services prennent de
mauvaises
habitudes et par conséquent il faut au
moins qu'un minimum de dispositifs
techniques soit mis en œuvre
pour permettre à la commission d'exercer
son contrôle alors je vais pas insister
là-dessus mais nous avons donc fait par
anticipation des travaux
d'agrandissement notamment de notre
salle qui permet d'accéder aux données
des enregistrements et des
transcriptions des services en matière
d'interception de téléphone mais demain
il faudra aussi euh pouvoir recevoir des
données d'autres techniques
naturellement donc nous portons cette
salle qui comporte aujourd'hui deux
postes sur des appareils spécialisés à H
postes possibles de façon à rendre aussi
des avis dans les délais qui nous sont
impartis par la loi
24h donc nous menons ces travaux il
faudra aussi des travaux
d'agrandissement de nos locaux d'autres
part j'ai décidé voici déjà quelques
mois par anticipation de cette loi de
créer au sein de la commission parmi les
cadres de catégorie A non pas un service
mais un embron de service
technique de manière à ce que nous
puissions apprécier les données
techniques et notamment les dispositifs
techniques qui nous sont proposés par
les services je veux dire par là que
comme je l'ai dit la Commission a étit
composée pour l'essentiel de magistrats
je parle pas des parlementaires je parle
du président et de ses
collaborateurs mais moi je ne suis pas
en état d'apprécier ce qu'on me dit sur
la nature des dispositifs techniques par
exemple des logiciels informatiques qui
sont employés par les services pour
gérer leurs
données et je crois que il faut que nous
ayons un œil c'est la raison pour
laquelle au 1er septembre dernier un
ingénieur
euh
mathématicoinaticien est venu nous
rejoindre j'espère que le président de
la CNCT pourra pourvoir au moins un
autre emploi de même nature de même en
vue de prévoir l'élargissement de la
future Commission l'élargissement des
demandes qui lui sont
adressées j'ai aussi recruté en quelque
sorte par anticipation un autre chargé
de mission égal magistrat de l'ordre
judiciaire qui vient donc renforcer la
capacité juridique portter désormais à
trois magistrats qui est arrivé ce
magistrat donc le 10 septembre
dernier ça ne s'arrêtera pas là moi j'ai
demandé au Premier ministre et
semblet-il obtenu mais je n'ai pas
encore le résultat définitif 18 emplois
pour la future
cncttr dans le cadre de l'année
budgétaire 2016 mais nous avons donc
accru les effectifs
avec l'accord du Premier ministre cela
va de soi puisque c'est lui qui tient
les cordons de la bourse si je puis dire
avec le Parlement ça va de soi aussi et
nous avons donc une insuffisance de
crédit'y reviens en terme de
rémunération cette année il doit être il
est prévu puisque j'ai eu l'autorisation
que ces crédits soient naturellement
abondés pour pouvoir financer notamment
les deux recrutements auxquels j'ai
procédé alors sur la sur le passage de
témoins d'une commission à l'autre
moi je n'ai qu'une préoccupation c'est
que l'efficacité du contrôle reste
identique et ne se perde pas en
qualité la loi a pris un semble de
dispositifs les uns qui me paraissent
infiniment heureux les autres que je
trouve personnellement insuffisant je
l'ai fait savoir publiquement mais j'ai
arrêté mes commentaires évidemment au
moment du vote de la loi et
après mais il y a aussi je voudrais
attirer l'attention des parlementaires
sur ce point un grand nombre de
dispositifs techniques qui doivent être
mis en œuvre si par exemple on utilise
une balise instrument qui était déjà
fort utilisé alors même que son
utilisation n'était pas
régulière il faut que ce qui est
recueilli par la
balise soit soumis à la commission qui
contrôlera si les données correspondent
au véhicule et à la personne déclarée
car la commission je me permets de
revenir sur ce point a bien un contrôle
à priori mais elle a aussi un contrôle à
postériori sur la base des données
recueillies par les service et c'est ce
contrôle à qui nous permet de vérifier
la véracité de l'autorisation qui est
donnée la véracité des indications qui
nous ont été fournies et la conformité
de l'exécution de l'autorisation par les
services donc les deux choses sont
absolument indispensables en l'état je
n'ai pas suffisamment de garantie
technique pour imaginer que je vais
avoir un contrôle sur les balises sur
les sonorisations sur les IM catchur et
autres instruments nouveaux de la même
nature de la même efficacité que celui
que j'ai sur les interceptions de
sécurité en matière d'interception de
sécurité je vais terminer là-dessus
madame la Présidente pour ne pas
allonger mon propos nous avons dans nos
locaux d'où l'esté est protégé
efficacement tous les enregistrements
dès lors qui ne sont pas supprimés au
bout de 10 jours comme le veut la loi
actuel au bout de 30 jours comme le
voudra la loi de demain et nous avons
copies de toutes les transcriptions
qu'en font les services de police c'est
une façon pour nous de vérifier la
conformité des choses demain j'ignore
quel volume de données vont être
recueillis par les services qui ne sont
pas trop diseres sur ce point
aujourd'hui même avec des gens qui sont
astreints au secret défense et d'autre
part je ne sais pas comment vont me
parvenir ces données donc il y a là un
ensemble technique qui me fait penser
que nous allons avoir une période de
transition technique pendant laquelle il
va falloir bricoler un tout petit peu et
je ne voudrais pas je le redis parce que
j'y tiens énormément que ce bricolage
qui va nous être obligatoire qui ne va
être
contraintad le contrôle que N que je
tiens je crois nécessaire à un emploi
raisonnable de méthode de surveillance
qui porte nécessairement atteinte à la
vie privée
voilà madame la Présidente ce que je
voulais dire monsieur le rapporteur euh
j'ai conscience d'avoir touché un peu au
fond de l'activité et sans doute
peut-être pas suffisamment sur la forme
que revê cette autorité administrative
indépendante un peu singulière un peu
limitée en effectif un peu modeste en
budget qui ne fait pas parler
d'elle-même car elle en a pas besoin ou
plutôt elle a besoin de discrétion voilà
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de cet
exposé liminire je donne la parole à
notre
rapporteur
merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président de la
rue je voulais tout
d'abord et je l'aurais pas fait souvent
depuis le début de cette commission
d'enquête vous rendre hommage et vous
dire
combien vous représentez pour nombre
d'entre nous l'exemple de l'indépendance
et de ce que doit être au plus haut
niveau le ce de la
République vous présidez cette
commission depuis pratiquement depuis
une bonne
année
considérez-vous que vous
aviez les
moyens
d'assurer la
protection de la liberté de nos
concitoyens c'est ma première question
elle est
fondamentale puisque je me permets
d'ajouter que quand même dans le le
document que vous nous avez fait
parvenir vous avez constaté des baisses
de budget avec un
accroissement de de mission et que c'est
clairement exprimé dans le document que
vous avez bien voulu nous faire nous
transmettre je crois que pendant
longtemps les effectifs ont été
suffisants contrairement à ce qu'on
affirmé quelquefois certains médias nous
n'étions pas une caricature de contrôle
nullement nous avions le temps nous
avons toujours le temps dieu merci de
réaliser un contrôle approfondi sur les
demandes un peu d'exercice nécessaire
mais on y vient et je crois d'ailleurs
que les services sont
aujourd'hui suffisamment suivis mais il
est vrai que mettons depuis 3 qu
années mes collaborateurs me disent je
n'étais pas là
qui sont un petit peu à la peine et nous
avons l'impression quelquefois de
manquer un petit peu de temps ou
d'effectifs pour apprécier comme il
faudrait les demandes qui nous sont
soumis surtout nous n'avons vous nous
avons voulu épargner autant que possible
cette activité là d'autres en
souffrent nous avons dans notre champ de
compétence je n'en ai pas parlé pour ne
pas alourdir mon propos également la
visite des centres GIC qui sont des
centres d'écoute déconcentrés il y en a
une vaintaine sur le territoire national
je me suis trouvé il y a pas tellement
longtemps par exemple en Guadeloupe ou à
bobini ces centres doivent être
absolument visités car c'est l'occasion
pour nous de vérifier j'allais dire
pardon de cette familiarité à la base
comment les services travaillent et s
respectent les prescriptions de secret
de destruction des documents par
exemple la baisse de nos budgets a
automatiquement engendré une baisse des
déplacements parce qu'il fallait bien
renier sur quelque chose et par
conséquent nous avons limité ces
déplacements nous
voudrions visiter chaque année à peu
près entre 7 à 10 centres
et comme il est indiqué dans le document
que nous avons fait parvenir en 2014 le
chiffres a été net inférieur et ça peut
donner ça l'impression au service que
leur activité est moins suivie j'ajoute
à titre personnel si je peux me le
permettre que pour moi c'est une
occasion d'échanger très
librement avec des fonctionnaires de
police ou de renseignement qui font un
travail
admirable et c'est là que j'ai appris
par exemple que alors que nous avons
nous autres à statuer sur des délais
dans des délais extrêmement brefs sur
les demandes qui nous sont soumises
comme il doit être d'ailleurs le cas
entre le moment où le policier de base
et le moment où cette demande nous
arrive il s'écoule à peu près maintenant
6 à 8 semaines bon c'est dire la
quantité d'information qui est perdue à
cet égard bon mais je reviens à mon
propos c'est dire aussi le type
d'information que je peux recueillir
dans ces centres donc
diminuer la fréquence de ces
déplacements c'est diminuer la notre
capacité d'écoute des services des
services dans leur réalité même et donc
nous soustraire à une certaine valeur
d'information qui pourrait nous éclairer
sur les demandes qui nous sont soumis
alors ces demandes encore une fois sont
examinées comme il
convient mais
euh nous ne faisons pas tout ce que nous
voulons c'est clair bon après tout
chaque fonctionnaire pourrait vous dire
la même chose mais euh je crois par
conséquent pour précisément votre
question que oui sans doute la capacité
de contrôle et donc euh cette espèce
d'équilibre entre liberté et
surveillance est un petit peu
atteint je vous remercie de cette
réponse monsieur le Président
euh vous
avez donc connu pendant cette cette
période et vous connaissez encore le
fonctionnement d'un collège dans lequel
il y a des des
parlementaires compte tenu de l'activité
actuel et si l'on peut se projeter
sur l'activité future euh quel est votre
avis sur la présence des
parlementaires alors elle a été discutée
dans les débat du printemps sur la loi
sur renseignement et d'ailleurs dans le
rapport annuel que nous avons rendu en
juillet au Premier ministre comme vous
l'avez peut-être lu monsieur le
rapporteur il y a un article d'un des
membres de notre commission qui est
président de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale qui exprime lui un
avis très ferme sur l'anestité où nous
serions de ne pas avoir de parlementaire
parmi la commission bon moi si je peux
exprimer très librement un avis je vais
faire référence un quart de seconde avec
vutorisation madame la Présidente sur
une précédente expérience d'ï qui est
celle de contrôle général des lieux de
privation de liberté et j'avais souvent
eu l'occasion de dire au parlementaire
peut-être monsieur mesard me l'a-t-il
entendu dire qu'il fallait bien que le
contrôleur soit contrôlé par quelqu'un
et je trouvais que le Parlement était un
instrument formidable à cette fin et
pour moi l'association étroite vous m'en
donnez une fois de plus l'occasion du
Parlement au travaux des Aï est quelque
chose d'indispensable alors soit c'est
un contact fréquent entre cette autorité
et le Parlement soit encore mieux le
Parlement si je puis dire est représenté
au sein de la commission mais c'est vrai
que le contact normal comme nous avons
aujourd'hui permet peut-être une
distance plus grande moi je suis assez
heureux il faut bien le dire quand même
que le Parlement se trouve au cœur de
cette activité régalienne euh on peut
craindre on dit souvent que les
parlementaires il a des risque de F et
cetera je je suis très simple avec vous
bon parce que c'est ce que j'entends
dire depuis 30 ans il n'y a pas eu un
seul une seule évasion je dire de la
commission donc à cet égard les
parlementaires ont été exemplaires et ce
que nous avons eu autour de nous je
parle de ma propre expérience et celle
de mes prédécesseurs également a été
tout à fait positive donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi je je j'émettrai un avis qui
serait défavorable j'y ai trouvé
beaucoup d'avantages beaucoup
d'avantages ce n'était qu'une question
monsieur le
Président votre avis euh nous nous
intéressait sur sur ce plan parce que ça
a fait débat et il est ou important
d'avoir d'avoir votre
avis sur il y a aussi eu un débat sur la
viis conforme et et je je je je je
comprends les observations des uns et
des autres les autres j'ai une position
mais je comprends l'autre mais quand vos
avis ne sont pas suivis d'abord
pouvez-vous nous dire
euh pourquoi ils sont pas suivis hein et
et et avec la nouvelle Commission
euh les les les conséquences que cela
peut avoir bon cette année à plusieurs
reprises le Premier ministre n'a pas
suivi vos avis bon p pouvez-vous nous
dire pourquoi et ce que vous en
pensez je crois pouvoir dire que il y a
eu en effet depuis un an moins j'espère
que ça n'est pas lié à ma seule présence
un
infléchissement de la politique du
premier ministre je je ne vise pas une
personne je vise la fonction
naturellement à cet égard
puisque nous rendons très peu d'avis
défavorables faut-il le rappeler c'est à
peine plus d'un %
même si par ailleurs je tiens à le
préciser plus d'un quart désormais des
demandes sont àorti de commentaires et
quelquefois de réservve par exemple en
diminution en diminuant le délai de 4
mois qui est le délai normal à 2 mois
dans certains cas par exemple pour un
mineur
euh mais très peu d'avis défavorable
nous mesurons bien évidemment que
lorsque les services nous demandent
quelque chose ça n'est pas pour des
fausses raisons il nous arrive aussi
pour éviter ces avis défavorables de
recourir à ce que nous appelons une
demande de renseignement complémentaire
c'est-à-dire que nous nous nous nous
donnons un surc à statu à la demande et
nous demandons au service des précisions
sur une motivation que nous jugeons
insuffisante à sa demande et nous les
avons toujours bon et ces deux éléments
la demande de renseignement
complémentaire et euh les les les
éventuels commentaires un avis favorable
éclaire en partie le faible nombre
d'avis défavorables que nous rendons
mais il y a des avis défavorables c'est
très clair il y a VI défavorable lorsque
nous estimons que les conditions légales
ne sont pas remplies ou que la
motivation même assorti de renseignement
complémentairire ne nous a nullement
convaincu quant à au bien fondé de la
demande du service par exemple on nous
présente quelqu'un comme extrêmement
dangereux ce sont des faits qui sont
très ancien pas de fait récent et cetera
bon jusqu'à 2014 en très gros ses avis
défavorables étaient pratiquement
toujours suivis à de très rares
exceptions
près et comme vous l'avez
dit un plus grand nombre n'a pas été
suivi en fin 2014 début
2015 bon il faut être clair je je crois
que c'est c'est ces avis défavorablement
suivis s'expliquent essentiellement pour
des raisons de
conjoncture c'est-à-dire que le premier
ministre estime contrairement à notre
pensée
que le dossier est crédible par exemple
ou que surtout en
opportunité il estime que le service a
besoin des renseignement qu'il
demande là où les choses sont très
délicates et je m'en suis ouvert à la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement je ne vais aborder aucun
dossier évidemment individuel mais je
préfère aussi vous le
dire c'est lorsque l'on touche au
domaine qui est celui où police
administrative et police judiciaire se
rejoigne il est des cas en
effet où la personne dont on nous
demande la surveillance au titre de la
police
administrative et soit parce que la
presse nous l' dit soit parce que la
demande en fait l'aveu l'objet d'une
saisine de l'autorité
judiciaire dans ce cas-là de deux choses
l'une soit la FA pour lequelle on nous
demande la surveillance est complètement
distincte de la faire pour lequel
l'autorité judiciaire est saisie dans ce
cas-là il peut y avoir une autorité une
autorisation et nous disons avis
favorable et avec à sortie de cette
formule rituelle sous réserve des
compétences de la don l'autorité
judiciaire est saisie les compétences de
l'autorité judiciaire dans la mesure
sais et puis y a l'autre cas beaucoup
plus difficile où c'est la même affaire
alors là la règle est très simple il ne
peut pas y avoir de police
administrative là où il y a police
judiciaire autrement dit la compétence
judiciaire l'emporte en
totalité les cas qui ont été les plus
difficiles pour
nous sur lesquels nous avons eu aucune
hésitation juridique c'était des
cas un peu délicats on va dire et même
dangereux pour les personnes mais
l'autorité judiciaire est saisie et par
conséquent nous avons rendu un avis
défavorable qui dans certains cas
exceptionnels n'a pas été sa mais ce qui
est nouveau aussi cette année ce qui me
paraît encore plus
significatif heureusement très faible
nombre c'est que lorsque nous estimons
que une autorisation a été donnée cont
j'ime la loi nous autorise la loi 1991
elle n'a pas été changée sur ce point
depuis nous autorise à adresser une
recommandation Premier ministre pour lui
demander d'interrompre l'interception
que nous jugeons illégale et depuis le
début de cette année nous avons adressé
en ce sens deux recommandations au
Premier ministre qui n'ont pas été
suivies alors c'est son choix
naturellement et je le respecte tout à
fait sauf que ce faisant il prend
évidemment des risques juridiques et des
risques politiques mais c'est à lui de
les apprécier en tout cas jamais depuis
1991 un premier ministre n'avait passé
outre une seule de nos recommandations
ça s'est produit deux fois cette année
je suis un tout petit peu je l' écris
dans le rapport donc je peux permettre
de vous le dire monsieur le rapporteur
madame la Présidente je suis un peu
préoccupé de cette
évolution
alors dans la suite de vos propos compte
tenu de ce qui s'est passé
des évolutions législatives de la loi
renseignement il paraît tout à fait
indispensable
d'avoir un
collège à la fois dont
l'indépendance béton armé parce qu'il
s'agit de la
protection de la liberté de nos
concitoyens mais aussi de ne pas faire
en sorte que la liberté des concitoyens
aboutisse à à des
dérapages inverses donc c'est
extrêmement c'est une mission délicate
et vous avez
bien vécu monsieur le Président deux
expériences de président d'autorité
administrative
indépendante une en tant que contrôleur
euh général des lieux privatifs de
liberté et et et vous avez été tellement
indépendant que euh notre Assemblée a
considéré que il fallait que cette
autorité reste indépendante et ne
rejoigne pas le Défenseur des droits
exact
mais vous ne pouvez pas douter que pour
beaucoup d'entre nous nous l'avons fait
en raison de votre
personnalité vous
présidez la
CNCIS et il va y avoir une mutation et
aveca les ouvertures
entre guillemets faites par la loi
renseignement je parle d'autant plus
facilement d'ouverture que je ne l'ai
pas
voté cette indépendance est est encore
plus
indispensa bon nous lisons la presse
vous
aussi il semble que vous n'ayez pas
souhaité être
le président de cette nouvelle autorité
indépendante je vous vois
opiner est-ce bien la réalité monsieur
le Président
oui monsieur le rapporteur le le
communiqué du Conseil d'État dit la
vérité sur ce point j'ai
exprimé le mois dernier au Conseil
d'État ma décision de ne
pas demander
le à être nommé parmi les membres qui
seraient se désigner par le
vice-président du Conseil d'État
euh naturellement
euh je n'avais pas de droit à occuper
quelque poste que ce soit dans la
nouvelle Commission ça ne c'est pas
comme ça que la République fonctionne
très bien mais si le vice-président
avait pu avait voulu penser à moi je je
l'en ai dissuadé
euh je vais pas m'étendre ici parce que
je ne veux pas réveiller des débats qui
ne sont pas ceux qui vous occupent mais
je l'ai fait parce que je pense que la
loi renseignement d'une part et les
techniques de saisir des données d'autre
part ne me donne pas les garanties d'un
contrôle
suffisant et pour une raison très simple
je ne souhaite pas par conséquent
m'associer à ce dispositif c'est tout
simple bon je respecte tout à
fait le fait que le Gouvernement a
souhaité une loi la Commission le
souhaitait aussi 80 % des parlementaires
j'ai fait le compte l'ont voté c'est un
événement dans notre vie politique j'en
tiens compte mais j'ai le souhait de ne
pas m'associer à cet
élan
alors l'indépendance si vous me
permettez d'extrapoler un tout petit peu
ça serait pas la peine de faire des
autorités qui font suffisamment débat si
les personnes qui les composent ne sont
pas
indépendantes et pour moi c'est c'est
sûrementf pas la première ça n'a pas de
sens il y a d'autres qualités qui sont
indispensables mais la première vertu de
ces
fonctions il faut
savoir
pouvoir dire des choses qui ne sont pas
forcément celles qui plaisent mais aussi
pouvoir dire des choses qui vont dans le
sens de la pensée
générale parce que sinon nous
n'apporterons rien nous n'apporterions
rien au pouvoir exécutif et au Parlement
mais il faut être très vigilant sur les
conditions de son moi j'avais béni le
parlementaire et per c'est surtout le
Sénat qui avait ajouté ces ses
dispositions dans la loi du d'octobre
2007 sur le contrôle général des lie de
préation liberté les conditions de
l'indépendance avaient été assorties de
dispositions très précises n'est-ce pas
mandat non révocable mais non
renouvelable j'aime beaucoup
ça contrôle de la Cour des comptes mais
pas du comptable bon il y a des
conditions désormais pour les autorités
indépendantes dont le législateur a
sorti leur indépendance qui me paraisse
très bienvenue et d'ailleurs j'avais
fait notamment comme commentaire un
avantprjet de loi sur les renseignements
qui m'avait été communiqué au Premier
ministre de de lui dire qu'il fallait
que dans cette loi figurassent des
dispositions de cette nature là bon
elles y ont été mise un petit
peu mais après c'est un état
d'esprit bon je me permets évidemment de
dire que le le
le la personne qui est pressenti mais
vous l'apprécierez vous-même monsieur le
rapporteur à la commission des lois je
pense d'ici peu le président pressenti
par le Président de la République
présente toutes les garanties à cet
égard j'en ai la
conviction donc un autre frera très bien
la
faire et si je peux me permettre en
remontant le fil de vos propos de
parvenir à votre introduction s'agissant
du contrôle général de privation liberté
j'espère que le Sénat aura d'autres
considérations que ma personnalité pour
décider du sort d'une loi et d'une
institution je pense que la la situation
des établissements pénitenties des
commissariats de police dans ce pays
n'est pas si enviable que on se prive
d'une autorité indépendante qui est
spécialement dévolu à cet effet je crois
d'ailleurs avoir dit à la commission des
lois de cette assemblée lorsque elle a
bien voulu m'entendre au moment de ma
nomination en juin 2007 en juin
2008 que peut-être dans 15 ans serait
temps de de la fusionner avec d'autres
mais le moment n'était pas encore venu
et je plaide contre moi au bout de 6 ou
7 ans le moment n'est pas tout à fait
encore venu voilà monsieur le rapporteur
ce que je souhaitais vous dire merci
monsieur le Président
euh puisque vous avez l'expérience de
ces autorités administratives
indépendantes de de cette
nécessité surtout pour celle-ci
d'indépendance pensez-vous que on puisse
à la fois
être avoir une autre activité en même
temps qu'elle soit publique qu'elle soit
privée vous parlez de la CNCT oui non
enfin raisonnablement en tout cas
s'agissant du président euh je parle des
membres du collège il y en a quandme
très peu alors
voilà ça c'est une autre
question bon les parlementaires auront
leur activité dieu merci s parlementaire
s'agissant des autres c'est-à-dire des
magistrats je suis assez partagé
c'est-à-dire je pense que ceux qui
doivent se consacrer assez largement à
cette activité
euh doivent pour
l'essentiel se consacrer à au contrôle
des techniques de renseignement dont ils
sont chargés est-ce que la totalité du
collège va s'intéresser de près au
dossier quotidien je ne le crois pas le
flux sera trop important pour permettre
à 5 personnes de se réunir tous les
jours pour statuer sur ces dossiers ce
que j'imagine volontiers mais le futur
président décidera avec ses
collègues c'est que un petit nombre
d'entre eux une formation restreinte
semlement tous les jours examinera les
flux à charge pour le collège
entier de fixer la jurisprudence c'est
au fond un peu ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui la commission de trois
personnes
qui compose la CNCIS se réunit à peu
près une fois par mois plus si
nécessaire pour statuer sur les dossiers
qui ont arrêté notre attention et qui
nécessit une nouvelle décision de sa
part le reste des dossiers c'est c'est
du quotidien et c'est destiné à se fixer
dans les rails de cette jurisprudence
que la Commission arrê il est inutile de
réunir la commission plus souvent sauf
encore une fois situation exceptionnelle
et nous l'avons fait j' que la CNCT
fonctionnera de la même façon car je
vois mal neu personnes examiné
quotidiennement un nombre de demandes
que je ne sais pas chiffrer mais qui
devra donner réponse au Premier ministre
dans les 24
heures et j'imagine encore plus mal que
on est des segment de commission qui se
réunissent tous les jours dans des
compositions différentes ça serait
meurtrier pour fixer une jurisprudence
meurtrier entre
guillemets donc ceux qui se consacreront
encore une fois je sais pas comment elle
va travailler cette commission à titre
principal à cette activité oui je
souhaite que leurs autres activités sauf
enseignement chose comme ça soit la plus
restreinte possible et surtout pas de
soupçon de
rapprochement avec quelques fournisseur
d'accès internet que ce soit avec quelqu
opérateur téléphonique que ce soit et
avec quelques services de police ou de
renseignement que ce soit cela va de
soi alors il faudra veiller en effet à
ce que ça se réalise euh c'est au
président là-dessus qui doit être vous
l'avez un peu suggéré tout à l'heure
mais je reprends pas ça je reprends pas
votre portrait à mon compte euh il doit
être intraitable sur ces sujets-là pour
lui et pour ses collègues j'espère qu'il
le sera mais je n'en doute
pas monsieur le
Président il nous apparaît au fil
de de ces auditions qu'on retrouve dans
les autorités administratives des
indépendantes
très souvent d'ailleurs en application
de la loi que nous
votons mais pas
toujours des personnalités issues
essentiellement de la haute fonction
publique des grands corps Conseil d'État
cour des
compte
ETA bon à tel point que certains des
membres de la commission d'enquête on
parlait de de
nomenclatura euh et et en plus bon on
retrouve j'ai l'impression que ça risque
ça peut être le cas
aussi pour cette future Commission des
personnalités qui sont dans plusieurs
instance en même temps pas forcément
autorité administrative indépendante
mais bon par exemple Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature je dis ça par hasard
vous vous en doutez
bien est-ce que vous estce que ça vous
paraît quand même quand même raisonnable
ou quel est votre sentiment
là-dessus alors sur sur le les
caractéristiques qui sont attachées à la
plupart des responsables d'autorités
administrative indépendante oui vous
avez sans doute raison et si ce que les
caractères que vous avez donné sont
exactes je fais partie de la
nomenclatura tout à fait
mais ce n'est pas forcément péjoratif
non mais j'espère simplement être aussi
indépendant à l'égard des
caractéristiques de de la nomenclatura
que vis-à-vis des autres institutions
quelle qu'ell
soi alors je crois qu'il y a une
question quand même qui mérite d'être
soulignée c'est que la vertu
d'indépendance se trouve quand même plus
facilement parmi non
pas des personnes issues de l'éat des
personnes qui ont l'habitude d'habitude
de de d'activité juridictionnelle la
Cour des comptes la Cour de cassation
Conseil d'État ce sont des gens qui sont
appelés à se prononcer tous les jours je
me permets de le dire expérience faite
en pleine indépendance dans de multiples
affaires et après tout il est pas
illogique de s'adresser à eux pour le
surplus moi je vois pas d'inconvénient
qu'on aille chercher d'autres personnes
qui présenteraient d'autres garanties
d'indépendance je pense à une
institution technique comme l'arcepep
sauf erreur ça n'est pas quelqu'un qui
répond tout à fait au caractère que vous
avez donné mais c'est quand même un haut
fonctionnaire bon euh mais je ne vois
moi personnellement nul inconvénient à
ce que on aille chercher dans d'autres
professions je crois cependant que
l'indépendance
elle ne n'est pas du jour au lendemain
c'est un apprentissage l'indépendance je
le dis très simplement je le dis très
simplement et repassant puisque je suis
à la fin de ma vie professionnelle
repassant mes jeunes années euh je peux
je peux avoir quelques critiques sur
moi-même à cet égard bon donc euh tant
mieux si on a là un vivier il serait
dommage de pas s'en servir mais s'il
faut trouver ailleurs mais je n'y vois
aucun inconvent il y a aucune règle qui
impose alors ce que vous avez dit en
2uxèe lieu est beaucoup plus
préoccupant euh si en effet certaines
fonctions sont si délicates qu'ell exige
qu'on s'y consacre entièrement euh il
est dommage que euh on on ne on
participe à plusieurs activités
simultanément et surtout à des activités
qui risquent de peser sur les choix qui
sont faits dans l'autorité indépendante
ça veut dire qu'il n'y a plus
d'indépendance ça veut dire qu'il n'y a
plus d'indépendance moi je je vais tout
vous dire mais simplement quand même un
peu un peu discrètement parce que je ne
veux pas mettre en cause quelqu'un qui
n'est pas là mais il y a des il y a des
personnes dont le la la politique
d'autorité indépendante compromet leur
indépendance parce qu'elles ont des
viser sur d'autres champs d'activité
elle voudrait élargir et cetera et
cetera pour se faire il faut convaincre
un certain n de personne donc alors on
est plus accommodant avec
elle ces dangers là guettent toute
autorité quelle qu'elle soit mais
évidemment c'est très très
ennuyeux dans les autorités
indépendantes donc faisons en sorte que
il n'y ait pas de conflit d'intérêt pour
dire les choses très banales
voilà je suis là-dessus il faut être
résolu et je crois que le lustateur doit
doit y veiller moi je si si c'est le
sens de votre question j'y réponds très
très positivement cétait bien le sens de
ma question et vous l'avez compris ça
n'était pas neutre par rapport à à des
nomination
annoncé
euh madame la
Présidente oui je je disais à l'aparté
que je pense que sur le contrôle du
Parlement par rapport au Cai va y avoir
beaucoup de choses monsieur le
rapporteur à dire est-ce qu'il y a des
questions chez nos collègues Pier
Colomba président revenir sur cette
notion d'indépendance
et vous dit vousê qui contrôlera le le
contrôleur
euh est-ce que vous auriez une idée
justement pour
euh permettre ce à la un contrôle qui
qui n'empêcherait pas le le bon
fonctionnement de de de de ces diverses
institutions parce que on a l'impression
effectivement d' d'un foisonnement et
surtout on a l'impression que
beaucoup d'autorités administratives
indépendantes ont été créé en
réaction au mieux à un problème au pire
à un
scandale ce qui est pas forcément une
bonne condition de de de de création
donc est-ce que je pense que vous avez
déjà un peu réfléchi à ça comment on
pourrait justement ben un peu réguler
euh tout ça et et notamment permettre un
certain contrôle bah de gens qui sont
censés être indépendants mais qui sont
pas indépendants de leur milieu qui sont
pas
indépendants de leur carrière qui sont
pas indépendants même SS n'ont aucune
même si moralement ils sont intgre euh
on n'échappe pas totalement à son milieu
comment vous est-ce que vous avez
réfléchi un peu à ça et est-ce que vous
pourriez n donner quelques pistes de
réflexion
oui dans vos propos monsieur le sénateur
il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs thèmes
euh je je dirais par boutade vous me
pardonnerez euh vous me pardonnerai
peut-être que même si une loi est votée
à la suite d'un problème ou d'un
scandale c'est pas rédhibitoire il peut
y avoir de très bonnes lois qui sont
votées après un problème ou un scandale
euh on a inventé le contrôle des
interceptions de sécurité à la fois à
cause d'un scandale bien connu sur les
gouttes téléphoniques je n'y reviens pas
et à cause d'un problème qui était la
légalité du dispositif français ou
plutôt d'absence du dispositif français
après deux arrêts de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme sur la question en
le 24 avril sé 1990 donc c'était à la
fois un problème et un scandale je suis
pas certain que la loi 1991 soit une
mauvaise loi je suis convaincu que c'est
une bonne
loi euh alors sur la maintenant la
réalité d'un contrôle euh
moi je crois que
traditionnellement le Parlement a pourvu
à cet exercice d'une manière très simple
il oblige chacune des autorités
administratives indépendantes c'est la
règle générale à produire un rapport
annuel et ce rapport est en principe je
l'espère soumis au Parlement moi j'ai eu
la chance en tout cas dans les deux
autorités que j'ai eu le privilège de
présider de remettre ses rapports annuel
aux présidents de chacune des chambres
qui ont bien voulu me recevoir et
d'évoquer ses rapports devant les
commissions des lois monsieur mard s'en
souvient sûrement
euh des deux assemblées c'est une un
moment
d'explication je vous en prie il y a une
quarantaine d'autorités administratives
indépendantes donc si on continue il
faudra créer un parlement spécial
oui n'empêche que c'est quand même la
voix qui est prise aujourd'hui euh je
crois que la fonction de ce rapport
annuel c'est bien d'éclairer les
autorités publiques le Parlement par
conséquent d'abord et avant tout plus
que l'opinion encore même si dans
l'esprit des autorités de certaines
d'entre elles en tout cas c'est
peut-être l'opinion mais pour moi c'est
les autorités
public j'ajoute pour aller euh à
l'encontre de votre observation le
rapporteur mais c'est pas une
contestation euh j'étais encore à à
rabas ce matin et je discutais hier avec
euh le président du Conseil national et
droits de l'homme qui présente chaque
année un rapport au
Parlement alors le Maroc n'est pas un
modèle de parlementarisme démocratique
peut-être mais sur ce plan-là il est
intéressant de savoir que ce rapport est
discuté chaque année par le Parlement il
est entendu par le Parlement en séance
il a une heure pour
s'expliquer alors vous me dites en effet
cette façon de faire multiplié par 40 et
même plus d'ailleurs est impossible vous
avez raison
alors moi je crois
que il faut sans doute différencier les
modes de contrôle suivant peut-être les
intérêts des assemblées
parlementaires et moi je ne vois pas
d'inconvénient à ce que certaines
institutions par exemple les
institutions récentes ou celles qui
portent sur des domaines régaliens ou
celles qui portent sur des sommes de
marchés engageant des sommes importantes
ou celles qui font peser des risques
majeurs je pense à l'autorité de Sté
nucléaire soit plus suivi que je vais
dire des méchancetés sûrement qu'on va
me reprocher l'Autorité de régulation
ferroviaire ou je ne sais quoi bon mais
je me trompe he
sûrement mais il est possible de
diversifier alors on peut sans aller
jusqu'au parlement bis que vous évoquiez
créer aussi un office parlementaire
dédié au aux autorités administratives
indépendantes de telle sorte qu' une
sorte de de dialogue un peu un peu
continu et puis comme monsieur rorteur
et madame la Présidente le rappelait
tout à l'heure il y a aussi la
possibilité de mettre des parlementaires
à charge pour eux d'informer leurs
collègues dans le collège même de
l'autorité alors est-ce qu'on peut
encore aller au-delà
euh moi je vois pas de d'inconvénient à
ce que telle mission parlementaire à
l'occasion d'une prérogative habituelle
à l'occasion d'un budget par exemple
viennent une fois tous les 5 ans
etplucher de près le budget de quelques
autorités administratives indépendante
je rends compte de mon budget chaque
année aux commissions parlementaires aux
rapporteur des commissions
parlementaires peut-être qu'on fait on
peut faire plus en la matière de façon
générale comme on le sait moi je
souhaite depuis longtemps je l'ai écrit
ça me gêne pas de le répéter que le
contrôle du Parlement sur l'exécution
des lois soit renforcé je dis une
balaillité
euh mais peut-être que euh on peut
spécialiser aussi certains
parlementaires euh sur certains aspects
d'autorité administrative indépendante
lorsque j'ai rencontré la délégation
parlementaire au ciignement on m'a
indiqué à propos de tel parlementaire
mais celui-là maintenant connaît bien la
matière bah tant mieux si c'est le
parlementaire qui sera désormais désigné
désigné ouilà mon mon interloccteur
habituel moi je crois qu'on peut
peut-être instituer des sortes de
délégations qui serait plus
personnelle pour être en quelque sorte
j'emploie des termes un peu empruntés au
au régime du droit commerciales des
censeurs d'une autorité administrative
indépendante au fond met bien dans
certaines d'entre elles des commissaires
du gouvernement pourrait mettre un
censeur
parlementaire donc je crois qu'il y a
différentes façons de faire ce que je
crois en tout cas c'est que il faudrait
exiger des des autorités indépendantes
dans le cadre actuel de vous présenter
des rapports même si vous n'avez pas le
temps d'en voir tous les auteurs qui
vous servent effectivement peut-être
faut-il demander aux autorités
administrative indépendante après coup
de bien vouloir amender corriger
rectifier la manière dont elle rédige le
rapport pour qu'il soit pour vous plus
utile plus intelligible plus plus
immédiatement utilisable
c'est pas toujours le
cas donc même dans le cadre existant je
crois qu'on peut faire des choses et on
peut sûrement aller plus loin dans
l'organisation de travail parlementaire
et on peut aller peut-être encore plus
loin mais je rêve sans doute à voix
haute dans le rapprochement de certains
membres du Parlement avec certaines
autorités administratives indépendantes
voilà ma
réponse
Pierry d'un autre
ordre tout à fait différent bon disons
que là en
théorie des écoutes un suivi enfin et
cetera on a donc un
individu pour lequel on pense que il y a
des raisons donc d'avoir de le de le
suivre bien mais est-ce
que les
techniques ne permettent pas de passer à
à une autre façon de procéder il
semblerait on a déjà des exemples
notamment chez les Américains que
finalement on
recueille tout un ensemble de
renseignements de micro renseignements
qui ne sont pas forcément des
renseignements relatifs à de la
délinquence ou à des possibilités de de
délinquence mais qui permett d'avoir une
vue non pas de ce que fait un individu
mais d'un champ d'un ensemble
d'individus plus ou moins repéré plus ou
moins qui ensuite peut être la peut être
la matière à un contrôle social et un
contrôle véritablement qui n'était pas
prévu qui n'était pas prévu au au début
est-ce que précisément le développement
de certaines techniques j'ai cru
comprendre que vous étiez attentif à
pouvoir maîtriser justement ces
techniques comprendre bien ce qu'elle
possibilité liciteou illicite elle elle
donnerit est-ce que vous pensez pas
qu'il y a là un un un risque si si si
vous avez tout à fait raison monsieur
monieur sénateur c'est un risque
considérable
euh la loi de 1991 sur les interceptions
de sécurité règle la question puisque
dans les transcriptions qui sont faites
par les services de police et c'est l'un
des objets de notre contrôle à
postériori il est interdit de transcrire
des choses qui ne sont pas en rapport
avec laquelle avec l'affaire pour
laquelle la surveillance a été demandée
et notamment tout ce qui est vie privée
doit disparaître tout ce qui est
relation
avoc doit
disparaître c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous tenons tant nous autres à
la Commission à avoir le contrôle à
postérior c'est poursivre l'exécution de
cette prescription par les services
demain nous accumulons les données en
plus grand nombre et sur un plus grand
nombre de
personnes et nous sommes obligés de
revoir en
effet l'échelle des
distinctions dans l'intrusion de la vie
privée traditionnellement nous pensions
que les écoutes de correspondance étai
le sommum de l'intrusion et que le
recueil d'une données technique de
téléphone n'apportait rien la
géolocalisation en temps réel se fait
sur uniquement sur des données de
connexion et si on vous explique
Jean-Marie de laarue est au cinéma alors
qu'il devrait se trouver en ce moment au
lieu de de sa séance de de de de
d'audition au Sénat euh c'est pas
négligeable
donc nous accumulons toutes sortes de
données et la séparation des données
sera évidemment de plus en plus
difficile la loi évidemment garde le
principe il faudra retirer de toutes ces
données recueillies tout ce qui n'a pas
trait à l'affaire ma crainte c'est que
nous ne soyons pas en mesure encore une
fois de vérifier assez tôt que ces
données sont soustraites et par
conséquent si par exemple
je reprends le cas d'une balise que j'ai
déjà évoqué parce que je crains beaucoup
sur les balises par c'est un
instrument qui se met sur une voiture et
qui n'est pas relié à un réseau et s'il
faut attendre le retour du véhicule ou
plutôt le retour du véhicule et le
retrait de la balise pour que son
contenu soit
assimilé qu'est-ce qui va se passer si
le service de police recueille dans
l'ensemble des données des choses qui
n'ont rien avec l'affaire et qui ne me
transmettent que l'affaire elle-même je
ne saurais pas qu'ils ont d'autres
données que se passe-t-il si dans cette
balise il y a des données qui sont en
rapport avec cette affaire qui concerne
telle personne et une affaire qui n'a
rien à voir qui est suivie par le jeu
judiciaire sur une affaire pénale d'une
autre affaire parce que ça sera le même
instrument qui aura serv servi dans les
deux cas à deux moments différents
comment est-ce que va se faire le
tri tout ça suppose une bonne foi des
services de police à laquelle je crois C
naturellement mais qui vaut mieux
vérifier parce que nous sommes en
démocratie et donc vous avez raison de
dire que l'accumulation des données fait
courir un plus grand risque
d'accumulation de données dont en
réalité les services n'ont pas besoin
mais moi je ne connais pas un policier
j'en ai fréquenté quand même quelquesun
depuis maintenant assez longtemps qui ne
soit pas soucieux d'accroître toujours
sa connaissance et de stocker toujours
plus de choses dans sa mémoire
n'importe quel policier vous dira qu'un
bon policier c'est celui qui a de la
mémoire bon et donc fichier et cetera
fichier dont certains d'ailleurs issus
de ces données ne sont pas aujourd'hui
contrôlés par l'acnil ils le seront
demain en principe grâce à la
loi alors pour tout ça j'y reviens je
suis désolé mais j'insiste il faudra que
d'une part la fasse son travail et que
d'autre part la Commission CNCT fasse
aussi le sien et si elle n'a pas les
technique de le faire alors on arrivera
au panorama que vous évoquez qui est
tout à fait réaliste tout à fait
réaliste d'autres questions mes chers
collègues non monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le
Président
avec l'expérience de de ces dernières
années
pensez-vous crédible qu'il y ait des des
activités de renseignement qui est
échappé au contrôle de la commission
oui c'est
crédible
alors il y a d'abord des activités qu'on
a qualifié
aimablement sans doute pour pas
effaroucher de zones
grises il faut quand même appeler un
chat un chat ces activités étaient
illégales dans la mesure où il n'était
pas autorisé ces activités là étaient
pratiquées à une échelle que je ne peux
pas définir puisque la commission n'en
avait pas le contrôle de toute façon et
pour cause elle n'était pas lesgal
ou mais il y a sans doute des
activités de descou téléphoniqu qui ont
pu échapper à not entier contrôle alors
il y a plusieurs façons de faire mais je
vais indiquer celui qui me paraît le
plus banal vous savez que depuis un
d'années ne sont pas
autoriser des numéros de téléphone à
suivre mais des
personnes ce que nous dans le jargon
abominable nous appelons des
objectifs un bon délinquant un
délinquant bien organisé n'a pas un
numéro téléphone il en a
10 par conséquent les services vont nous
demander
peut-être d'abord dans la demande
initiale TR ou quatre numéros qu'ils
auront identifié et puis au fil des
écoutes ils vont s'apercevoir que la
personne en question notre objectif il
en a d'autres donc ils vont nous
demander d'écouter aussi ils auront
raison les autres
téléphones c'est ce qu'on appelle dans
notre jargon des listes modifiées
c'està-dire que il nous présente et ça
ça n'est pas soumis au Premier ministre
il nous présente des demandes pour
information des demandes il nous
présente des listes modifié c'est-à-dire
des listes où sont ajouté des numéros de
téléphone qui n'avaient pas au début ou
bien où sont retranché des numéros de
téléphone qui sont révélés superflu par
exemple la
personne n'utilise son téléphone que
pour des raisons strictement
familial bon donc nous avons tous les
jours un de listes
modifié les services du GIC qui nous
aide beaucoup dans notre tâche de
contrôle par la force des choses pour
des raisons techniques je peux pas
expliquer ici m à peu près 15 jours
avant de savoir
si la personne qui est entendue par le
service de police correspond bien à
celui de la demande et si le motif pour
lequel un numéro est demandé correspond
bien aussi au motif pour lequel il a été
demandé donc moi je suis un service de
police j'ai envie d'écouter quelqu'un
dont je ne veux pas qu'il soit connu je
veux dire la surveillance soit connue
qu'est-ce que je fais ben je demande un
numéro attaché à une personne puis je
présente une liste modifiée dans
laquelle je mets un numéro concernant
une tout autre personne et je vais le
pouvoir l'écouter tranquillement pendant
15 jours et puis je vais le retirer dans
une deuxième liste modifiée au bout de
15 jours et le service de GIC n'aura pas
eu le temps de s'en apercevoir et nous
non
plus donc il est crédible que des choses
a été faites sans notre contrôle je
pense pas que ça soit très important en
volume mais il y a des asuce pour ça et
donc c'est tout à fait
crédible je vous remercie de cette
réponse monsieur le
Président vous vous une dernière
question vous nous si j'ai bien compris
d'ailleurs ça avait
été expliqué très clairement au cours
des débats sur la loi renseignement que
cette loi permettrait finalement de
légaliser des
pratiques que vous avez appelé grise bon
malgré
cela vous vous venez de nous parler du
passé avec la loi prochaine est-ce que
la poursuite ou la modernisation de
nouvelles pratique grise est
envisageable selon vous j'avais indiqué
au gouvernement très tôt c'est-à-dire à
l'automne 2014 que je souhaitais que la
loi fut conçue de telle sorte que au
fond conformément à l'article 34 de la
Constitution elle ne porte pas sur les
techniques de renseignement mais sur les
degrés d'intrusion de la vie
privée ce cette façon de voir n'a pas
été suivie c'est c'est tout à fait
légitime de la part du gouvernement mais
on se trouve déjà en porortfo puisque
maintenant les techniques qui ne sont
pas mentionnées dans la loi sert réputé
illégale or l'évolution technologique et
c'est ce qui a d'ailleurs motivé la loi
elle-même l'évolution technologique même
si la loi de 91 a très bien vieilli à
cet égard mais l'évolution
technologique est galopante dans notre
domaine je vous prends un exemple
euh le drone personne n'a parler de
drone dans cette loi et demain la
préfecture de police a déjà un drone bon
et demain le survol de propriété privée
peut poser problème après tout est-ce
que il y a une différence entre poser
une caméra dans l'intérieur d'un
appartement et le faire
survoler enfin faire survoler un
appartement non mais propriété on va
dire bien non il n'y a aucune
différence et donc est-ce qu'on va
assimiler le drone à une technique
existante bah c'est un peu difficile
donc non et pourtant on nous dit
déjà la police a vraiment très besoin de
ces
affaires donc je crois que l'approche
choisie par le gouvernement et le
Parlement encore une fois ils sont
évidemment libre de leur choix n'y voyez
aucune critique mais pour moi me paraît
être de nature à entraîner ce que vous
venez de dire c'est-à-dire le
développement de techniques dont les
services vous diront toujours qu'ils en
ont besoin et sans doute avec raison
euh et par conséquent le développement
de zone grise j'ajoute aussi que ce qui
est très intéressant et ce qui a été peu
évoqué pendant les débats c'est le
développement mais un petit peu le
développement de de techniques de
cryptologie de
cryptographie je discutais la semaine
dernière pour ne rien vous cacher ma
demande avec le directeur de la sécurité
de Google international qui est un
personnage un peu
important et à qui je posais la question
de savoir si Google répondrait à ces
demandes très fortes de ses usagers de
cryptologie et il m'a dit oui sans aucun
doute et d'ailleurs la police se plaint
déjà et un procureur bien connu à Paris
a écrit sur ce sujet en disant que la
cryptologie faisait courir des risques à
la répression de la délinquence
oui mais alors il faudra inventer des
contre-mesures sans doute mais ces
contremesures elles-mêmes alors elles
vont nécessiter des techniques et ces
techniques elles seront est-ce qu'elles
seront toutes autorisées est-ce que
toutes se rapprocher se raccroché à
celle qui existe je n'en suis pas
certain donc j'aurais voulu que le
législateur évite de reprendre ce
chantier en permanence pour suivre les
évolutions technologiques je ne suis pas
sûr que on y ait réussi voilà je vous
livre tout àraque mon sentiment très
personnel monsieur monsieur rapporteur
merci monsieur le
Président pas d'autrre questions
monsieur rapporteur non non bon on va
vous remercier monsieur le Président je
pense que votre audition a mis très en
avant la nécessité du contrôle du
Parlement hein je pense qu'on en a parlé
peut-être plus avec vous que avec
d'autres et c'était utile moi je je
pense que on peut pas se contenter de
dire que le rapport d'activité annuel
est un un moyen de contrôle c'est une
information le rapport d'activité et je
dirais que c'est peut-être une source
pour justement aller faire tel ou tel
contrôle au niveau du Parlement je suis
pas sûr non plus que avoir des
parlementaires dans les
institutions ça soit dans les
Aï ça soit une une bonne chose non plus
suffisante du point de vue du contrôle
parce que l'expérience montre que les
parlementaires qui appartiennent à telle
ou telle institution la défendent tout
naturellement on voit ça dans des
conseils d'administration de grandes
société d'ailleurs et voilà publ ou
autre donc voilà je pense que vraiment
le problème du contrôle se pose vraiment
du contrôle par le Parlement il y a
l'aspect du Parlement qui doit se poser
des questions quand il légifère sur tel
ou tel Aï pour avoir un petit peu de
logique sur l'ensemble de ces
institutions je pense que là il y a tout
un P mais il y a aussi tout le pan du du
contrôle qui apparaît très important et
vraiment je vous remercie de d'avoir
répondu très directement et complètement
à nos questionnements merci beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le rapporteur merci Monsieur
voilà vous avees donc pu suivre
l'audition de Jean-Marie de la rue
devant la commission d'enquête sur les
autorités administratives indépendantes
Jean-Marie de la rue qui s'est dit lors
de cette audition préoccupée par la
nouvelle loi sur le renseignement il ne
prend d'ailleurs pas la tête de la
nouvelle Commission nationale de
contrôle des techniques de renseignement
vous pouvez revoir bien sûr cette
audition sur notre site internet
publsenat.fr